take you know probably the worst
turbulent seas kind of experience and
multiply by about ten and that's the
potential that we're going into that's
the voice of Justin Kibbey
he's a pilot my job title says hurricane
hunter pilot yeah he flies planes
through hurricanes it's all in the name
of science
he works for NOAA the National Oceanic
and Atmospheric Administration these
missions are for data gathering to track
and study hurricane paths and movements
but Justin Kibbey and I aren't talking
about data we're talking about what it
feels like to fly an airplane through a
hurricane
[Music]
it starts to get cloudy and once you're
in the storm you'll start to hear rain
hitting the windscreen it can be very
loud
it's surround you surrounded the whole
plane are the best we describe it if you
have ever lived in a house with a tin
roof it's hard to hold the conversation
inside
these are the conditions Hurricane
Hunters fly Fuu every time they go on a
mission because the point of flying
through a hurricane is to fly through it
and get to the eye and he was telling me
about the first time he ever did that
that was 2010 we're flying into
hurricane Earl
the latest information we're getting
about Earl Cho a hundred and thirty five
miles per hour and still getting
stronger and then I remember breaking
out into the eye of the storm everything
just kind of stopped everything still
always stopped lighting stopped
pitch-black out you can see stars above
you really beautiful serene it's quiet
and it was a holy [ __ ] Bookman was just
what do we just do what just happened
and a bolt of lightning lit up the
entire outbound eye wall where I could
see it visually and also go man that's
gonna be scary it was a rough ride on
the way out but I'll never never forget
it it was probably one of the coolest
that I've been on
[Music]